One of the really cool features of 23andme results,
is when you can combine your Ancestry and Traits information
and you can do this when you have family
members that have results to see. You can see exactly
which alleles you share with which family members. Let's
take Joanna Mountain's family as an example. Here's her family
tree or pedigree. This is Joanna, this is her husband
Heyward. Her children Myles and Seamus and their grandparents, David,
Susan, Anthony and Tasha. One big question that
Joanna and her husband had about one of her
children, Seamus, is that he has blue eyes while
both of his parents Joanna and Heyward have brown
eyes. Of course Joanna knew that eye color
was determined genetically, which meant that she knew that
Seamus' blue eyes must have been passed down from
her and her husband. And ultimately from their individual
parents, Seamus' grandparents. So Joanna set out
and coded their family tree or pedigree
here. With the eye colors of her children. Her and her husband, and their
parents. Now unfortunately, the maternal and paternal
grandfathers were deceased. But the paternal and
maternal grandmothers were still alive. And we
know that they both had brown eyes.
And the question was. Were either of them contributing
to the blue eyes that we see in Seamus? So
a simple saliva sample from each and every one of
the six individuals that we know something about here was
collected. Now one of the alleles important in determining eye
color is a gene called HERC2. Which we'll learn more
about in Lesson Nine. Now without explaining the whole story,
one allele of HERC2 is recessive and promotes blue eye
color and another allele is dominant and promotes
brown eye color. So, for Seamus to have
blue eyes, that must mean that he inherited
two recessive copies of the HERC2 gene from each
of his parents. This means that Seamus is
homozygous recessive. And each of his parents, Joanna and
Heyward are heterozygous dominant for brown. And the
question is, where did these recessive alleles come from?
Which of Seamus's grandparents, in this case
his paternal or maternal grandmothers, did they contribute
a recessive allele to his eye color?
So after submitting a saliva sample for everyone
in the group, the 23andMe website allowed
the family to compare their chromosomes side by
side. In this case we're comparing Seamus' chromosomes
with his paternal grandmother and here we're comparing
his chromosomes to his maternal grandmother. Everywhere you
see a shade of blue in which it indicates
shared ancestry meaning that some of his chromosomes
have inherited a piece from that individual grand parent.
Any where you don't see shading means that
they don't share that piece of the chromosome. And
the red arrow indicates the location of the HERC2
gene on chromosome 15. So looking at comparison of
Seamus' chromosomes to his paternal and maternal grandmothers, which
grandparent did he inherit one HERC2 allele from and
why? Go ahead and select which grandmother you think,
and then tell me why in the text box here.